[Musica]
che cosa unisce il panda gigante il
bufalo di mindoro il coniglio fluviale
all alice merica ai bombati dal naso
peloso sono tutte specie animali in via
di estinzione ed ormai socialmente
accettata l'idea che questa strage sia
causata da noi esseri umani guidati da
attività come la distruzione la
frammentazione dell'habitat che il
bracconaggio è una cosa da vergognarsi
non pensate anche voi è imperdonabile
l'idea che l'uomo cosiddetto sapiens sia
capace di una tale atrocità e cupidigia
e se possedere al contrario deve dire se
non ci fosse alcun colpevole per questa
sesta estinzione di massa ma forse tutto
parte di una sequenza di eventi del
tutto naturali che avvengono da sempre
nell'universo pensavo recentemente alle
storie che raccontiamo noi stessi a cui
in qualche modo finiamo per credere e
che a lungo andare definiscono la nostra
realtà le nostre convinzioni ciò che
prendiamo lo sia vero falso ciò che le
persone credono di noi influenzano le
nostre decisioni grandi e piccoli che si
sa se un giorno scoprissimo che le
nostre convinzioni non fossero vere come
sarebbe diversa la percezione che
abbiamo del mondo se fosse vero il
contrario quali studies di
spiegherebbero davanti ai nostri occhi
alla domanda è se fosse vero il
contrario
e ce lo chiedessimo incessantemente ogni
giorno quali scelte opportunità potremo
cogliere se solo guardassimo il mondo
con lenti nuove sono un esploratore e la
prima volta in cui e b dimostrazione di
quanto diversa potesse essere la mia
visione del mondo solo adottando un
atteggiamento più critico circa le
verità che socialmente vengono prese per
vere fu quando poco più di 20 anni
sognavo di attraversare un oceano remi è
impossibile mi dicevano me lo sentivo
ripetere così di frequente che questa
voce era difficile da ignorare
finché un giorno dissi e se fosse vero
il contrario
e fu proprio a partire
quella scintilla di possibilità che si
era accesa dentro di me che feci i primi
passi e poi altri passi ancora finchè va
bene attraversato due dirigenti da quel
tutto da lì da quello spiraglio di
possibilità originata da una visione
laterale da quelle due esperienze tante
altre che sono venute prima e dopo a
contatto con una natura
alle volte stile potente ma alle volte è
fragile e venuto il desiderio di
documentare il mondo che cambia e
difendere il nostro diritto di vivere in
un mondo accogliente
oggi sono impegnati in un progetto
chiamato the universe uno show con cui
mi propongo di navigare 10 fiumi più
inquinati di plastica al mondo con
questo progetto mi sto facendo un'idea
molto precisa delle cause delle delle
possibili soluzioni a questa crisi
ecologica e se di tutto quello che so
sulla crisi ecologica fosse vero il
contrario se scoprissi che i termini
ster sin qui parlo di questo reale
problema fossero sbagliati che non sto
veramente toccando il punto focale che
cosa ne sarebbe delle mie convinzioni e
di quelli delle altre curiose sti
cominciamo con l'idea proposta da
ambientalisti filosofi esploratori e
quindi anche da me dobbiamo
riconnetterci alla natura questa
rappresenta la quinta essenza del
pensiero ecologico moderno in risposta a
un disaccoppiamento tra uomo e natura
per opera della cultura occidentale e se
ci fossimo riconnessi troppo la natura e
con la scusa di riconnettersi e ressa
l'abbiamo trasformata maltrattata
sfruttata per servirsene come un
servizio un prodotto da consumare nella
genesi c'è un verso che forse spiega
l'origine di questa disaccoppiamento si
legge ed io li benedisse e disse loro
crescete e moltiplicatevi riempite la
terra e rendetevi la soggetta e dominate
sui pesci del mare sugli uccelli del
cielo e sopra ogni animale che si muove
sulla terra anche un dettaglio
linguistico piccolo come questo modello
il modo in cui pensiamo al mondo
naturale e poiché il linguaggio stesso
che usiamo per descrivere in modo
naturale traccia una linea tra uomo e
natura è difficile per noi non pensare a
noi stessi come separati
non so proponendo il divieto di
passeggiare nel bosco di fare una gita
al lago
anzi questo ci può far altro che bene ma
di restituirle i suoi spazi
e l'essenza di soggetto da rispettare
non di oggetto da sfruttare la seconda
idea che vi propongo riguarda il
concetto di protezione della natura
se ci pensiamo mai come ora i temi
ambientali sono all'ordine del giorno di
governi situazioni di soggetti economici
anche di normali cittadini
ma paradossalmente mai come ora il mondo
naturale in sofferenza un vecchio claim
delle campagne di protezione ambientale
dice che l'uomo deve proteggere la
natura e se fosse vero il contrario non
può essere che il problema stia proprio
nel modo stesso in cui si parla di
protezione e poi proteggere da chi da
noi esseri umani e se non ci fosse
nessun ambiente da proteggere
quando pensiamo alla terra da una
prospettiva evolutiva
ci rendiamo conto che la vita sulla
terra è sempre stata soggetta al
cambiamento
perché quindi il mantenimento di uno
stato particolare considerato ideale e
richiede protezione a quale periodo
della terra vorremmo dovremmo tornare in
quale periodo della vita dell'uomo sulla
terra c'è stato un giusto equilibrio
la natura umana e quella delle piante e
del pianeta intero sono in continua
trasformazione in questo caso sarebbe
una grossa contraddizione voler
proteggere quello che c'è ora lo status
quo perché l'idea di natura è quella di
una relazione che si instaura tra
l'ambiente e gli organismi viventi e
quindi anche le tra l'ambiente l'essere
umano
quindi se invece di promuovere il
concetto di protezione
se sottolinea se l'idea che tra noi
stessi e l'ambiente esiste una redazione
di co evoluzione che può essere migliore
o peggiore non potrebbe essere questa
una via perseguibile
così facendo abbandoneremo l'idea
irrealizzabile di proteggere un ideale
ambiente immaginarlo e ci concentreremo
sul processo dinamico di coltivazione di
un insieme di relazioni che modellano
che siamo
non si tratterebbe più di fare azioni al
turistiche ma semplici azioni egoistiche
in questo ruolo è molto abile la terza
idea riguarda il concetto di crescita
sostenibile una forma gentile di
crescita e che si è fatta avanti
gli economisti in cerca di una soluzione
che da una parte rispetti l'ambiente e
dall'altra che rispetti anche il nostro
bisogno il nostro sogno di fare soldi e
affascinante l'idea di potersi servire
dell'ingegno umano e della tecnologia
per far crescere il pil e
contemporaneamente ridurre l'impatto
climatico l'impatto ambientale della
produzione e se fosse vero il contrario
cioè se crescite economiche tutele
ambientali non potessero coesistere
secondo un rapporto pubblicato nel 2019
la crescita verde non può esistere ci
sono diverse ragioni per essere scettici
riguardo al verificarsi di questo
disaccoppiamento tra crescita economica
e impatto ambientale per il futuro
saremo quindi destinati per sempre a
scegliere tra prosperità e ambiente
pare di sì almeno finché non riusciremo
a pensare a un'economia equa che rimanga
all'interno delle capacità di carico
della biosfera o come è stata definita
dall unione europea vivere bene entro i
limiti ecologici del pianeta
certo arriva sempre il punto in cui
dobbiamo definire il confine tra diritto
alla sopravvivenza umana alla
moltiplicazione del sé alla supremazia
dell'uomo e all'avvicendarsi naturale
delle cose
ma qual è questo limite io non ho una
risposta
quello che sogni quando non trova una
risposta ogni tanto devo avere il
coraggio di guardare dalla parte opposta
credere cioè che l'assunto di partenza
sia sbagliato e vedere quali strade si
aprono davanti a me nei giorni scorsi
pensavo all'uomo vitruviano a
quest'opera di leonardo da vinci classi
noni mo di equilibrio
l'uomo al centro di un cerchio ma il
centro anche di un quadrato sono lontani
quei tempi
come possiamo ritrovare quell'equilibrio
e continuare a pensare in termini di
riconnessione protezioni di crescita
sostenibile non sembra sortire alcun
effetto
allora forse l'unica strada perseguibile
la strada su cui stiamo camminando in
questo momento un percorso di totale
distruzione
alla fine del quale ci sarà forse spazio
per un nuovo momento di creazione e solo
quel punto la vera evoluzione potrà
cominciare
intanto non me ne sto con le mani in
mano
da quel giorno io continua a navigare
sui 10 fiumi più inquinati di plastica
al mondo
[Musica]